coucou Virginie l'actualité est assez
anxogène en ce moment et je me demandais
comment ça va
toi écoute ça va et toi hein on fait ce
qu'on peut hein bah comment ça va toi
comment ça va toi pas sûr qu'il y a des
grandes périodes dans la vie même si euh
mes parents ont connu une période sans
guerre et tout ça mais qui a eu des
grandes périodes sans aucun conflit avec
tous ensemble main dans la main vers une
joie une paix éternelle la paix jamais
en fait etternet est est remise en
question en permanence mais euh
s'interroger sur comment ne pas laisser
certaines pensées médiocres moches
gagner du terrain comment ne pas chacun
se mettre dans un clan ne pas défendre
que son propre camp d'abord c'est quoi
un camp en plus B bon bref allez voilà
quoi tu vois ce que je veux dire donc
non ça va pas c'est la merde c'est la
merde c'est la merde